so today we're going to go back to am i
the [ __ ] uh the forums on reddit to
read about some some of those cases that
have to do with thanksgiving we have a
number of mi the muscle thanksgiving
related dilemmas thanksgiving is a time
where lots of people act like apples
unfortunately
here are a few of those cases these are
some good dilemmas i think a lot to talk
about so we'll read through some of
these
first me and my wife had a baby seven
months ago my parents came to us for
thanksgiving dinner this year my wife
made a great spread as we were about to
eat the baby started fussing he has been
teething
i told my wife she should go attend to
him but she asked if i could because she
hadn't eaten all day because she was
trying to care for the baby cook
everything and try to visit with my
parents and she would really like a warm
meal instead and it had been a while
since she'd had one i said it'd be
really rude to my parents to sit down
without me since in my family the
hosting family member was always at the
table with the guests my wife asked me
again to please go but i was annoyed and
said no i could tell my wife was
irritated but she went to our baby
i was thinking we'd wait for her to
return but my dad said he was starving
and everything looked fantastic
so i told him to dig in my wife seemed
to be having a hard time getting our son
to settle down but she's always had the
magic touch when it comes to him so i
left her to it
that was very nice of you by the time he
was content and quiet again we'd
finished and we had moved into the other
room
i had left everything on the table and
when i went back around she was feeding
the baby i said she should probably
clean up once she was done
and she really coldly asked when exactly
she was supposed to eat i was taken by
surprise and asked what she was on about
and she told me that she hadn't eaten
anything and i had left a mess instead
of at least taking the used dishes to
the sink and she she knew it was too
much to think i'd actually be bothered
to make her a plate too
i got irritated and told her that she
was being dramatic
that we were hosting and i thought it
was more important to spend time with my
parents she said that i was the one who
invited my parents over but i left her
to do everything i said that wasn't true
but she asked me to name just one thing
i'd done to help her i was put on the
spot and i couldn't think of something
so she said exactly i got pretty angry
but my mom came in then and asked if she
could feed the baby my god are you still
talking my wife said yes
then started making herself a plate so
she could eat
my mom was upset with me when she
realized that my wife still had need
okay first of all
before your wife ate
did you make sure that she had cleaned
the bathroom because it's not it's not
fair to leave a messy bathroom when
their guests over no i you know i i'm
actually concerned that um as a as a
five-year-old you're probably way too
young to be married i mean i believe in
early marriage but that's too far i
think even for me i can only assume that
you're five and have been married for
five minutes based on your behavior as
you describe it
you know you know what you are actually
you you're like kevin james or ray
romano from a 90s like a 90s sitcom you
know
you did literally everything wrong every
step of the way he's in it
you're so wrong and outlandishly
polished i'm not sure if i even believe
that this is real but then the whole bit
breaks down if it's not real so we'll
just charge ahead and pretend that it is
um next one says i'll preface this by
saying that my son tim recently got
married to his now wife sarah we get
along just fine as a family though she
tends to act passive aggressively
sometimes she loves food and is always
open to trying my cooking
she said my cooking was amazing though
she made few a few negative comments
about certain meals and advised me to
use xyz ingredients next time
who are these people
so she sat down to have your meal and
say oh this is great but next time you
should try that ingredient this who does
that um i invited them over for
thanksgiving yesterday the whole family
was there the bell rang and i opened the
door to see tim and sarah sarah was
carrying what seemed to be a container i
didn't ask about it nor paid much
attention to it everybody sat down to
eat after i set up the table and put
dinner on it my main dish was the
traditional thanksgiving dish every
family in our community knows i had
appetizers and side dishes and of course
salad and dessert
sarah then put the container on the
table and started unloading food onto
her empty plate
everybody was watching as my eyes
widened up i asked what she was doing
and she said that she brought her own
food to eat since she won't eat what she
doesn't want to eat what i cooked i was
stunned and i politely asked
if there was a reason for that and she
shook her head
i asked if she was vegan she said no
asked if she was allergic to anything at
the table she said no i asked if she if
she was having an upset stomach or
anything she said no
she just sat with a smug smile and uh
which set me off and then anyway okay
then it goes on and on and on
and uh the this ungrateful
daughter-in-law eats her own meal at the
table while the sun just sits there okay
so yeah um sarah's an [ __ ]
but i put the blame on your son tim
really i think he's the bigger goal here
because what kind of husband allows his
wife to bring a tupperware container
with her own meal to his parents
thanksgiving dinner
i mean there are times when you put your
foot down as a man
and uh this is definitely one of them
although if you got to this point it
probably means that you've never you've
never put your foot down one time and
that's very obvious from this you're
leaving for thanksgiving dinner and you
see your wife holding a container of
food
and i could see asking like oh is is
that your contribution to the meal or
you bring no that's just for me
[Music]
oh you're joking right this is like a
craze this is one of your crazy
practical jokes right that's very funny
no no i'm serious
okay well then you're a lunatic and i'm
calling an insane asylum i here's what
we're gonna do you put that damn
container down or i swear to god i will
have you admitted to an asylum put that
coffee down that's conflict resolution
in a marriage okay that's what you do
you
so what is both the best-selling book of
all time and the best-selling book each
and every year you might be surprised to
hear that even today it is still the
bible i think we all recognize that the
wisdom of the bible has stood the test
of time and we also know that it's well
worth everyone's time to read this jewel
of a book but having time to read
anything these days is proving more and
more difficult that's why the audio
bible app dwell exists this five-star
app makes it so easy to get into the
bible by providing a world-class
listening experience that you have to
hear and see to really believe uh you
have to just try yourself so go to dwell
app dot io slash walls to try dwell free
for seven days this audio bible app
includes 12 different narrators each
with a unique accent which always keeps
your listening experience fresh there's
all of your favorite bible versions the
niv uh nk jv esv nrsv kgv and much more
you can weave in beautiful instrumental
music into the background if you like it
even has a really handy read-along
feature that combines both sight and
sound for increased comprehension
and this is a dwell up i've by the way
been using myself for a long time and uh
this is a great way not only to get
yourself into reading them reading the
bible but also your children as well so
you've got to try it for yourself go to
dwell app dot io slash walls to try
dwell for free for seven days plus if
you fall in love with the app which i
know you will they're giving all of my
listeners early access to their black
friday sales so go now to dwell app dot
io slash walsh and try dwell free for
seven days and begin your journey of
rediscovering wisdom and truth found in
this timeless book
um next my family gets together once a
year on thanksgiving i'm recently
remarried and my wife hasn't had much of
a chance to bond with my family due to
covid and we are all looking forward to
getting everyone together unfortunately
my elderly parents just told me that
they've also invited my ex-wife to
dinner which i'm adamantly against my ex
has known these people for 20 years and
that familiarity and level of comfort
will make it hard in my opinion for my
new wife to fit in she insists that i
could go without her but if she won't go
uh then i'm not gonna go as my place is
by her side my family says that my wife
isn't that very nice you're remaining
steadfastly loyal uh to your second wife
good that's a man of principle
my family says that my wife should just
suck it up and deal and that's um if
we're not there we'll ruin thanksgiving
for everybody so am i the soul for
thinking my ex should make other plans
and not attend my family's dinner
yeah you're the apple uh i think on a
number for a number of reasons you're
such an [ __ ] first is getting
divorced in the first place and this is
why you don't get divorced divorced
you just make everything complicated for
everybody you make everything worse and
everything complicated for everybody for
the rest of your life including yourself
that's what happens you get divorced and
your family keep in mind
when you get married
it's it's not just you it's just
the two of you are not the only ones
affected
you have families and your families are
now bonded as well through this bond of
marriage your parents it sounds like
have accepted your first wife as their
daughter as a member of the family and
now they're supposed to renege on that
they're supposed to reverse course just
because you have
their bond doesn't mean anything anymore
just because you've decided to sever it
it doesn't work that way
it's like when you you know when parents
get remarried and then demand that their
kids accept
the new person as their you know mom or
dad you're not my dad maybe they will
but that's not their responsibility
that's not their obligation
they have a mom and dad
they only need one of each as far as
they're concerned
the fact that you couldn't work out your
marriage and you decided to break your
wedding vows that's not anybody else's
problem that's your problem you you
figure that out
all right uh what else we got couple
more here here in canada it's
thanksgiving weekend and my family is
having our dinner tomorrow my aunt who
has a toddler and is in the middle of
moving insisted on hosting dinner this
year despite all of us warning her could
be a lot to do especially with her
moving she insisted that she'd be able
to handle it and the plan was to have
dinner at her place
i'm a baking and pastry art student so i
offered to make pies for dessert my
offer was taken up and i started
planning and designing the pies for my
family
this would be the first time any of them
had seen or tried any of my pancake
baking since i've become more than a
home baker i'm classically trained in
french pastries among other things and i
graduate this winter so needless to say
i take great pride in what i create and
consider each baked good a piece of art
and a piece of meat tomorrow is the
dinner and i was just informed that
there would be no home-cooked meal but
instead my aunt is going to order thai
takeout for everybody
i got upset and said that not only will
i not be making the pies but i won't be
attending to dinner at all my parents
are mad at me for not following through
but i feel massively disrespected and
disregarded
am i the apple uh i mean a little bit
yeah i think you are this is kind of a
half and half whole deal so you're the
[ __ ] for all the stuff about how your
baking is your art and it's a piece of
you and trying to impress everyone with
the fact that you're in college i went
to college that makes you an [ __ ] and
no one wants to be around that on the
other hand your aunt
is ordering takeout on thanksgiving that
is that that's a crime i mean that
should actually be a crime this isn't
hard okay thanksgiving is a time for a
specific sort of meal you should not
legally be allowed to eat
anything but
the traditional meal so we're talking
turkey stuffing green beans gravy sweet
potatoes et cetera right like there's a
few other staples you can add in some
variation you can add some things in
addition to the staples
your own twist on things if you want but
the staples need to be there and again
if you know when i'm theocratic fascist
dictator of the world this will be a
matter of of the law all
restaurants that serve takeout will be
forcibly closed on thanksgiving any
restaurant that tries to open on
thanksgiving will be immediately shot
that's it all right it might seem a
little harsh
but you got to break some eggs to make
some omelets
um finally i am married to my husband
and we have two kids we are vegans i am
for ethical reasons my husband is
allergic to dairy and so is my
three-year-old okay i'm gonna cut it off
right there you are the apple i don't
even need to know the entire story
vegans on thanksgiving are always the
[ __ ]
same with every other time of year in
fact
guys
and i don't want to hear about ethical
reasons see you won't eat dairy
because of
you don't think we should get milk from
cows why
what else should we do with the cow's
milk oh yes the cows exist what are we
gonna do with the cows first of all like
do you want us to just release them into
the wild
what all these cows that i mean i know
you could say it's it's it's unethical
that we have all the dairy farms
everything that's so terrible though
we've enslaved all these cows
um what do you want us to do with them
just bring release them into the
serengeti i mean bring them down to the
amazon just like release them into the
neighborhoods
kill them all
dump them into the ocean like we have
them
they need to be milked
and then what do you do with the milk
you might as well drink it why not drink
it why not make cheese out of it and
also what about the lives of the plants
that you're eating
the lettuce that you're eating is a
living thing vegans it has hopes and
dreams and and ambitions
and feelings
and you ruthlessly chop it up and stick
a fork in and chomp on it while it
screams silently in pain which you
ignore those screams take a head of
iceberg lettuce make sure the core is
pointing down and slam it
so don't come to me talking about
ethical concerns
especially on thanksgiving
you should all be in prison as well
anyway so um
yeah that's it happy thanksgiving happy
thanksgiving pilgrims
thanks for watching this video on
thanksgiving although you should all
really be not watching youtube you
should be with your families on
thanksgiving you're all [ __ ] but
while you're here make sure to like and
subscribe